get down and dirty whatever all right
ready
this is for both of you i start my day
doing what
atlantis breastfeeding
good answer sustaining life meditating
every day
that's how i start for how long um
well after going to joe dispenza's
week-long retreat and doing like 14
hours of morning
90 minute minimums like i did an hour
this morning
wow that's impressive if you were not
doing
what you're doing what would you be
doing
i'd probably be a an author keynote
talking and
was just kind of doing anyway so gosh i
could never see
that it's not some sort of therapeutic
something
yeah me too i would say that i've always
said i'd be i would
i was curious about being a therapist
yeah nice
i'm just i want to solve problems and
i'm so interested in the
nature of thought and um what's really
going on i'm very interested in truth
on every level so like like the truth
behind the emotion the truth behind
the pain whatever yeah yeah what's
happening underneath yeah
or maybe i saw the word cosmology and
saw the definition of it and i'm like
maybe i'd be a cosmologist
yeah i would like to be a reality of the
universe
i would like to be an esthetician
cosmologist
really i have i have about a thousand
archetypal like side
parallel universe lives you know there's
one part of me that has a shaved head
lives in india
she's been there forever then there's
another part that had no kids and she's
doing her own
magical thing there's a therapist who
dresses really
there's all these archetypes that are
being lived out because there's
in this particular lifetime there's only
so many you can do and i
squeeze in as many as i can but they're
probably happening i had an akashic
reading the other day and she's like
you're doing this like it's like a
binary star dance and you're doing this
in the play
syrian star system and i'm like oh wow
okay and
you know this life here and i'm like oh
god i'm just so fascinated with that
stuff
it's so fun i mean the whole
multiversity
wanted to be a singer when you were
younger i did i did want to be a singer
when i was
so the first thing i wanted to be was um
uh
a secretary because my sister and i when
my parents were working really late at
their glass shop
we would we would have this area that
was like
a table and we'd use old calendars and
pretend like we were secretaries
and the secretary then i wanted to be a
veterinarian because i love it
and that's a fun parallel universe are
you seeing the universes as you're
talking
yeah exactly well i wanted to be a
singer
and so i actually took lessons for um
one summer
and i um i got really weirded out by my
teacher because he would like touch my
stomach and things like that and i was
like he's kind of picky
and he's just like kind of just like you
know it's just like didn't feel right
and i was like and it was you know
closed doors and i was just kind of got
that vibe like i don't think i want to
be alone in a room with
no i love singing everything i sing
super loud and i'm obnoxious and i don't
even care like i'll be in the car i'll
be anywhere and i'll be like i just want
you to know i'd like to sing
and so just good enough for people like
oh you're pretty
and it's nice i'm like he asked by the
way when i turn the volume down in my
car by myself to check how good i
actually am i'm not so so never turn the
volume down
what makes me laugh is i used to like
using it about playing secretary i used
to play school
and then when the pandemic hit i was
like oh my god i'm playing school for
real
for real like i'm like making lists for
my kids on white boards you know what i
mean and i was like this is there's
something fun not funny obviously it's
very serious but there is something
humorous and light to the fact that now
you know you're sort of forced to do it
day in and day out
yes well that's that's your parallel
universe you have you're a teacher i
mean you are a teacher anyway
obviously in this position even maybe oh
that's interesting that's a nice thing
yeah thank you oh yeah yeah that's a
cool thing that is
pointless all right thanks what you're
carrying on
um what do each of you make sure that
you do before you take the stage or
the track um
yeah yeah did you have to have to pee in
your fire suit
i tried one time is that the indy 500
you know maybe my second year because
race car drivers would pee in our suits
because you have to
i'm saying we as if i did it i didn't
but um they because you're in the car
for like three to five hours and so
anyway i remember it's like the first
caution
at the indy 500 maybe my second year and
uh i remember thinking oh my god it's
only like lap
20 of 200 and appeal ready and so i was
like i was going down the front
straightaway
under caution i thought just go man
really did it work and i and i was like
nope ever since since i was ever since i
was 12.
i can't do this i couldn't do it
wow it's it's weird but it's there's
nothing worse than being on stage and
needing
to go to the back i would say also the
other thing is
other than yeah other than um especially
being on stage like people looking
at you and you're trying to move but
you're trying to
um but uh the other thing i would do too
is um
pray for sure yeah oh yeah
yeah for sure we my band mates and i we
we call it the huddle
and i'll just say an intention if
someone in our team needs some love or
an intention for the audience or
just setting an intention of why we're
even here